5 25 into Wednesday morning so we are
winding down another year what's driving
you crazy and I want to show one of my
all-time favorites from a couple years
ago State Police saw sergeant from
Indiana with a really cool safety tip
about your car that a lot of people have
apparently never heard of
but what if I told you there's a feature
on every car that's standard that not
only will help prevent crashes but also
help prevent road rage a little bit let
me show you to the left side of your
steering wheel there's this stick that
comes out it's pretty incredible it's
called a turn signal if you push it down
in front of your car it starts making a
light flash on the back of your car it
also flashes a life indicating that
you're going to turn left or make a lane
change and if you push it up it
indicates that you're going to go right
now this is not only the right thing to
do it's not only against the law not to
use it but it's the courteous thing to
do and it's going to help people around
you understand your indication that
you're going to make a lane movement or
make a turn so please use your turn
signal uh the Timeless words of Indiana
State Police Sergeant John Prine they
were recorded almost six years ago and
he points out that using your turn
signal may require you to put down your
cup of coffee or your phone or whatever
you might have in your hands and as I
say every day buckle up drive carefully
and please yes put on that phone you can
join the driving you crazy conversation
at traffic eight at eightnewsnow.com